It has been a while since I have talked about Elevation,
Bethel Hillsong,
those types of churches.
And so this video popped up for me today, um,
with this comment.
And so I just kind of wanna talk about a little more.
I have never personally attended Stephen Verdict's church.
However,
I have been influenced significantly by non denominational churches,
mega churches,
and I have listened to Stephen Furdick sermons a lot in my life.
Problem with Steven Furdick is he's very charismatic,
and he's a very gifted communicator,
which is why he's so dangerous.
Verdict teaches modalism.
He has said, god broke the law.
These things are heresy.
They're not in the realm of orthodox Christianity.
While those are a significant problem,
the biggest problem I have
is that they never give you a full gospel presentation.
These types of churches usually say, oh,
because god loves you so much,
and he just wants a relationship with you,
and all you gotta do is just have faith and you'll be great.
And while, yes,
faith is a huge part of our salvation,
it. That's not the full gospel.
But here's the bad news.
The bad news is that each and every one of us
have sinned against a holy and just god,
and therefore we are condemned.
We cannot save ourselves,
we cannot atone for our own sins,
and therefore, we need a savior.
Here's the good news is that Christ,
being merciful and kind and loving towards us,
Took our sin upon himself.
He lived a perfectly sinless life.
He became sin who knew no sin.
Was crucified,
died, was buried.
And he was resurrected on the third day.
So that you and I can have the gift of salvation.
And it is a free gift of salvation.
It is not one you can mere.
You cannot do enough good deeds to earn salvation.
You cannot say a prayer to earn your salvation.
It is only the gift of god to you if you believe in him.
Salvation is not a reward for the righteous.
It is a gift for the guilty and for the condemned.
And so that is why I will continue to talk about Bethel Hillsong
elevation. These types of churches.
Because they preach a damnable gospel that does not save.